and we were talking about portugal
against uh uh
conor mcgregor yeah and i made my
recommendation this is a part three of
fighting i think
i think if there's ever been a time
where a guy like if all the mobs
hypothetically purely hypothetical if if
the mobsters
exist i mean there's no such a thing but
let's just say if there was such a thing
as a mop we know
it doesn't exist it's just in movies
correct but if there's such a thing as
the mob
if there's ever been a time to call
somebody to take a dive
for a couple million dollars probably a
good time to do it right now
if somebody's gonna call and i'm not
saying it's gonna i'm not even putting
the idea out there all i'm saying is you
just did if dustin gets a call and says
hey
five million bucks just take a dive okay
why who do you think dana wants to see
the fight the hundred million dollars
nobody wants to see podium or gsp or any
of that
but can you imagine a khabib reunion
against
conor who comes back can you imagine
conor against gs can you imagine if that
takes place right
and the part we went to when we were
talking about uh um
how dana's uh doing what he's doing
where you can't take fights or any
sponsorships that you do they have to
they have to be only what you were
talking about they have to go through
the ufc it has to be the ufc sponsor
they can't get external money you can't
get
external sponsors it has to be only one
capitalize on your image and you know
you know you know what i was going to
say yesterday when i said i'm going to
say today on the podcast here's what it
is
you know who dana doesn't want as an
enemy same person jeff bezos didn't want
as an enemy
jeff pesos is more glad more open to the
idea paying more taxes
there's one thing bezos doesn't want
regulation union
oh not want union
ufc will get destroyed oh my god union
enters it by the way
if union enters it dana cannot be dana
they have to go get somebody like an
adam silver if
union enters ufc dana's fired
because they shut it down i don't think
i don't think they'd even go through
with it
no they wouldn't shut it down are you
kidding me any opportunity for the union
people to make money memberships taxes
oh hell no these are the most
capitalistic
i'm talking about i think zuffa and dana
white i think they i think they
they'd lock down the ufc they can't do
that though they can't do that when you
sell a company for that price and you
get three and a half billion dollars and
you got 10
350 you can't play those cards you just
cannot do it you're gonna you have so
many
they will put him in court for the rest
of his life to ruin his
life he's not gonna do that he's got a
great life but if you go
at bed with union that's not a that's
that's
one part that he has to realize if
there's anything that he has to just
yesterday so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye